[Applaus]
mit jedem tag mit jugendlichen offenbar
sind und sie dazu unterstützung in der
tat halfen bei richtigen kinder das ist
in der großartigsten wo man überhaupt
[Musik]
diese bilder sehr wundern was gedanke
personen in der form in der
realität ist die arena und hat immer
noch die landnutzung also
richter
schafft unglaublich was er alles schon
gemacht
[Musik]
auf
[Applaus]
sekundarschule lehrer dicker ist seit
kurzem pensioniert drei seiner
ehemaligen schüler innen schauen mit ihm
acht jahre zurück damals filmten sie
ihren alltag im letzten schuljahr in der
und da ist es dann wieder bis ins
rentenalter
ist ja die hat mich auf
ich hatte schon steht der zweite sektor
eins mit homburg
[Musik]
nutzen
unsere
politiker war es wichtig seine klassen
mit seiner heimat der innerschweiz bekam
zu machen besonders weil die
schülerinnen und schüler ganz andere
kulturelle wurzeln mitbrachten
30 jahre schuldienst im kanton schwyz
waren für prediger genug mit mitte 50
entschieden sich nach zürich zu wechseln
wo die klassen ganz anders aussahen als
in seinem heimatkanton
vom ersten bis zum letzten
wenn ich etwas befragt hat den 10 die
verschiedenen stämme und die
verschiedensten kulturellen hintergrund
aller meister mit allem ausser spielt da
sicher trainer war einfach ein bisschen
zu acht
verschiedene überhaupt wirkt und das ist
ja
nicht dass das ganze
musikalisch fasziniert
absolut genial ich weg
der wind bringen so rufen sie bringen um
zu bringen so viel vielfalt
weiter ihren kulturellen hintergrund
vertrauenskultur wo sie von der heimat
bringen lässt fasziniert und sie können
ganz anders miteinander um wieder so
schön homogenes vom rhein schweizer und
audi
das funktioniert
funktioniert ist in erster
linie meine mutter schuss columbia um
einen vater spitze also wenn die mutter
hat auch kein problem aber es ist
trotzdem nicht einmal karriere
ausreden vor dem interview vom
was ist wenn die wörter
und
konzentrierter summe richtet
[Musik]
aus dem filmmaterial des letzten
schuljahres entstand 2014 eine 13
teilige youtube miniserie über die
multikulturelle klasse und ihren lehrer
eine mission von judith den schülerinnen
und schülern gutes englisch beizubringen
später flog sie durch das macht
putschten englisch und ich studiere
jetzt ja englisch
[Gelächter]
begeisterte die eigentlich das frühstück
gemacht
was hat er bemerkt
erst wer ist dein kind über
ich bin ich befürchte eine von porto
daheim artistik und portugiesisch jetzt
informierte
alexander
alekseev
albert klicks ist abfang auf ihn
aufpassen
das sind geschafft und ich bin am mix
allein mit dem blick durch das bin ich
eigentlich auch ganz schnell
wachsen
ines filmte damals viele facetten von
sich selbst und offenbarte so einen sehr
persönlichen einblick in ihr leben
[Musik]
das war schon sehr lange
bis ich tot
[Musik]
ja
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
doch die habe ich alle da aber ich
meinte es ist okay es ist okay dass man
mal dick ist es ist okay das ist mal und
drama geht es ist könnten zu hause
soll was
für deren negative ist negatives bild
du bist du bist
jerusalems bist du erst so karten sind
ruhig
die erträge sind
wie festigkeit kommen
also
vor san diego san diego
und ich bin
und
mein körper gemacht ich bin einfach
ich muss
[Musik]
weniger flog mit seinen klassen jeweils
für drei wochen nach san diego
damit sie ihr englisch praktisch
anwenden konnten für die schülerinnen
und schüler die maximale aufregung
die meisten von ihnen war noch nie im
ausland ohne eltern und für viele der
damals 15 jährigen war es der erste flug
ihres lebens überhaupt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist eine schöne idee
das ist nun offen sie sind und im gb ich
weiß nicht 7 der bisherige abkommen ist
für yaz teilerfolge verzeichnet das weiß
ich doch schon so und das ist mit das
ist nie druck sie aber wirklich glauben
dass dieser stil vergeben
die meisten seiner abschlussklasse von
2014 haben eine lehre gemacht und
studieren jetzt einige wollten sich
nicht mehr vor der kamera zeigen benny
ines und meret gewähren uns nochmals
einen einblick in ihr leben andere
schickten ein filmisches update zum
beispiel oliver
wenn ich so lange da
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vermietern und der stabilität
ich habe noch das
kaufmännische lehre gemacht wieder login
haben des letzten jahres in berlin
verbracht
hätte nur zwei ja noch eine wieder
schafft warum haben die prozedur
nach militär im moment gerade bin ich am
studieren aber zeitfenster der
international management gerade im
ersten jahre zeit semester und ab
september werde ich in madrid für das
jahr
studiert und bessere aktuelle wohnens
lag aber immer noch so dass ich nach wie
vor dem motto warum zu hause
einfach finanziell schaffen und abb
jetzt das studium und welche möglichkeit
teilzeitpensum bin versichert ich hoffe
du darfst kann ich mir dass russlands
überhaupt möglich
[Musik]
statt sich sieht vor für eine
wundervolle freundin
glücklich die negativfolgen
mini materielle
werte
schaffen mit dem velo was ich so hinter
sonja noble inc
sowie vom 50 jährige über
seine frühen werke sowie das
menschliches wird so gut sie
[Musik]
gedanken macht
es immer wieder
[Musik]
hediger hat vor acht jahren wie seine
schülerinnen und schüler auch privates
von sich gefilmt
wo man wirklich
karibik und sicher von den alltagssorgen
erhole proben gott mehr wirklich
ausgestellt
stefanie hat davon profitiert nicht nur
als schülerinnen im englischunterricht
auch sonst lernte sie vieles und einiges
fürs leben
als lisbeth
hallo zusammen
mit stefanie und ich bin 2014
in der rede die abschlussklasse economy
anfang mittleren er damals und habe auch
unglaublich richtung freute
das kochen mache und dass natürlich
sowieso immer schon fasziniert die
branche gefunden
und erstmals eigenen ganz verlieren ich
auch richtig cool ja und da musste schon
fast draußen wenn nicht völlig kann ich
leider noch ein jahr hat es eher so für
ihren albtraum entwickelt der spd wo ich
kläre gemacht haben beschlossen die
reisebüro zuletzt mache und das habe ich
im ersten moment ein extrem
überforderung die situation gefunden
wenn möglich ohne lehrstelle halten dort
stand ich mit 16 ja
als schwierig von dem sie auch sagen
kann dann aber ein super neue wer platz
gefunden wie tui und können alle
kriminell er fertig machen sich alles
super xiii den anderen
damaligen und bms nach und nach das nach
der ehe und
anschließend dann sogar noch keine
gemacht als naturführer sind einfach
nicht so
unlustig lehrern und jetzt wünsch dir
ich auf der uni cd jura und es war
extrem gut ich bin super happy und
beetle im koffer einfach sonst nervöser
das ist schon hauptsächlich
studium ich bin seit zwei jahren in die
erste bezirk wohnen oder mini bringt
seine sondern in nrw um in 50 jahren
eigentlich gern mit dem weg geld das man
in leibnitz halbinsel plane es wird
schluss sein doch sowieso alles komplett
anders
machen wir richtig gemacht
schlichten beeinflusse wer hier als
rechnen
spox hier hätte es immer inspiriert
matchbälle als
die meinung jedes einzelnen zählte in
joes klasse das hieß alle mussten sich
einbringen und
lehrer hediger förderte kreativität und
selbstverantwortung in hohem maße
das fordert wir müssen gestaltet werden
auch ihr haus genügend zeit das problem
ist macht sparvorschläge
und zeigt sie uns und wir stellen dann
ob sie uns
ich möchte dass die plastik dahinter
stehen nicht nur die 2
das was man lieber nicht ich habe ich es
genau die experten kann wo außerhalb vom
fach
gegangen das ist meine ich dass ich mich
dass wir uns großes ali t ich bin
einfach nicht nur der vermieter das ist
einfach ein fachidiot
einfach nur dir und mir ist wichtig sie
passiert nur als spitzel besonders also
ich kann die sprache sehr geschätzt ich
weiß nur dass mir also
diskussionsrunde gemacht dann wollen wir
uns also auf teile und die eine und die
andere
ich glaube es ist schlimm bei einer
lehrperson so nicht kehrt und ich ganz
gut so wie jetzt mir im französisch mal
angespielt
haben die jedes mal richtig buchen
das pflanze dass bei gestellt hat aber
so
benny ist einer der wenigen der direkt
nach der sekundarschule und gymnasium
wechselte der beginn seines englisch und
spanisch studiums in basel vor zwei
jahren war für ihn das ankommen im
erwachsenenleben sagte
die krippe komplex k
das hat sich mit anderen vor allem jetzt
zeit aber nicht geben einfach will ich
jetzt selfmade bin wie stand da bin ich
aus eigenem antrieb und
nordosten anderen wahrscheinlich dass du
im spiegelzelt
um zu sparen lebt benny wie viele in
seinem alter in einer wohngemeinschaft
seine mitbewohnerinnen und mitbewohnern
sind ein paar jahre älter er hat von ihm
schon einige spieler
möglich wäre und jetzt kriegt marke und
konsum tasse kakao tanks der weg geht
dank mich will ich wusste
also was jetzt gerade im jahre machen
aber sowieso dass mir vor dass ich mich
so schweizer richtig ernährt und die
hand das hatten auch macht und
dicken waren wahnsinnig seine kritiker
wurden habe ich aber keine zukunft und
nicht dauernd so gewinnen 4 6 und einem
mittagsimbiss und wollte mich als
unternehmer will ich weiß dass es spaß
macht uns auch in konstanz
[Musik]
umgangssprache ist englisch da immer
jemanden der wie gewohnt der oder die
kein deutsch spricht und
sie pflegen eine intensive
diskussionskultur
also ich bin jetzt eine politische
gemeinschaft diskutiert werden
zusätzliche themen
[Musik]
work in warmen
vorherige generation
generation also drückt die
metapher le pain und versucht es besser
zu machen und danach eine sind dann
überrascht wenn es bitter ist für andere
generation besonders hoch
ist in top-form und ich sie und jetzt wo
es vorwerfen dass wir uns wir sind da
jetzt einfach auf fragen akzeptiere
jedoch sind wir in ordnung als zehnte
frau gekannt zu haben erste generation
wird das langsamer fort hinterfragen
afghanistan internet waren weniger keine
chance internet macht unsere jobs für
uns und jetzt hammerweg merkt auftakt
immer am letzten freitag im monat fährt
berlin mit seiner wg an der sogenannten
critical mass mit einer weltweiten
bewegung die mit fahrten durch die
innenstädte auf den langsamen verkehr
aufmerksam machen will
so ist auch hier jetzt kauft sich
vorstellen dass er karriere
[Gelächter]
gewählt
das einzelkind und
hotspots ist inzwischen so schön
der christbaum fast der bahn hunderte
abgesehen ein vater wie in der burg
landshut der stadt immer noch
auf 1 370 euro ich bin später mitnehmen
ich zwar respekt aber auch aus minister
kann zeigen sie sind doch stolz und
nicht
auf die rolle
der sprache
gebracht
natürlich leidet er will die soziale
netz und alles aber
zum teil sind sollte selber schuld wenn
sie nicht geeignet ich eine kv lehre im
profil wie mundl es zwischen
internationalen lebensmittel-hersteller
danach hanni mit einem schloss
großmann kurz machen dass anthony 1 jörg
macht also nur kurz begleiten und für
die post als erwachsene gemina colt
im zweiten jahr spezielle sion ist
letztes jahr eigentlich nur noch
die heillos kompakte krone pandemie das
militär noch
und dein letzter im september studium an
der universität st
wenn man dann single level eis und
caroline zweizimmerwohnung
und überwachen kann es zurück nach
zürich bild das ich nicht nach wie vor
mein lebensmittelpunkt show hätte er
sich sehr mehr geht es mir gegenüber an
den rand einer schülerin tägliche
altersstufen vorteil haben haben wir ein
extrem kurs besuchen noch der lehrstuhl
des champs cambridge toscani mensch
und er als mensch auch insofern dass das
eigentlich zählt ist dass man
verschwindet wohl so freut aus dem board
hat und das auch noch so lange zieht und
ja auch was man sagt man das selber
inspiration gehe bis finden hoffentlich
art und weise erfüllt
europa kamen hat von der hohen
sozialkompetenz und jungs klasse
profitiert
[Musik]
die flec machst mach du nach kult und
die profunde ich schaffe zurzeit als
sachbearbeiter vom sozialamt bitte
stoppt silly und von den im september
studium als sozialarbeiterin die
schweden im no 3 mit meinem hund
sich letztes jahr noch die us ca
den text zu jährige ich mich
lieber ins risiko
und sowieso alles ganz anders geplant
lausanne kräftig zurück ist happy dank
sehr gern zurück an die tolle sache mit
dem behäbigen und der no hand und das es
ermöglicht hat
singing christmas tree überrollt
wir schon
forschung und
pause gibt
[Musik]
sich dem anlass entsprechend zu kleiden
war pflicht bei lehrer hediger
[Musik]
ich sage ich möchte jetzt die feuerwehr
werde aber nützen erklärte die
miliz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist doch einfach einfach du bist du mich
anrufen
problem kommt
acht jahre später ist die familie für
ihn es immer noch sehr wichtig nachdem
sie einige jahre mit ihrem freund eine
wohnung teilte ist sie nach der trennung
wieder zuhause eingezogen
ihren lebensunterhalt verdient sie noch
immer in ihrem ehemaligen lehrbetrieb
als kundenberaterin
nach einer kv lehre mit berufsmatura
studierte ines ein semester
betriebswirtschaft war damit aber nicht
glücklich jetzt hat sie gerade die
aufnahmeprüfung an der pädagogischen
hochschule hinter sich und hofft dass
sie lehrerin werden kann
jetzt sind alle gäste und für den sich
die
winzerfamilie schade und suchen sie mal
einen blick im mini familie wie mercedes
will ich danke meiner kultur machen wir
das anders als jetzt mich geschützt
[Musik]
aber das netz das den ganzen
die freude am tanzen es geblieben heute
sind es die majoretten zürich für die
sie sich ins zeug legt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
natürlich mit der maus
zuschauer ruft letzten natürlich mega
kohlhammer jetzt zur krone von mir
natürlich auch weniger kam das natürlich
schaut ist aber mir freude dass immer
mehr planen auch immer wieder so was wir
nach dem
weihnachtsmann macht mit einer tanz- und
das silver hat das motiviert 1000
konzerte bühne auftreten für weniger
gleichwertig wie ein schulfach
[Musik]
[Applaus]
lisa barros
und umso weniger
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe
blut hat absolut
und einen schrank zu klären und ich
bin jetzt gerade hat sie mit leib und
seele und
ich habe mich nicht mögen die ich
zum ersten mal den
derzeitig darunter die einst so fix ist
aber
dadurch auch
der tollste lehrer muss sich manchmal
mit hormon geplagten teenies und
anspruchsvollen eltern herumschlagen
jährige holte sich die kraft in der
stille
oder wenn
irgendwas los war jetzt waren religiöser
mensch aber doch hin und wieder gegen
das was es tut mir einfach nur ich habe
im moment im doppel mit älteren schüler
und da will ich nie irgendetwas zu
machen was er wollte moment letzte woche
drei bis zerstört in der schule ist auch
verständlich sondern mehr lehrer
verständigt und ältere vor ihm die
scheibe trägt die vier episoden ich bin
ich das zwar kommt aber trotzdem
und meistens macht denn nur ein
spaziergang im klosterhof und
lebt wo sie tröstet sich und das einfach
design morgens
die energie wolle hier tanken auch in
einsiedeln auf dem spaziergang aber aber
also wenn ihr vorliege seien aber die
fehler die 100 euro wieder zu gut und
die bioenergie norwegische
mit deiner situationen besser umgehen wo
man ist gar nicht so einfach sind
ich weiß nicht was wir über 5000 unser
thema ist dass wir keine werbung gemacht
[Musik]
hilfe ich vor jahren
stockstadt
staubtrocken wie immer wir haben hier
eine kaution
so wählt ihr diese nicht kommentieren
null toleranz bei rassismus oder
diskriminierung das ist jazz oberstes
gebot im klassenzimmer
das hat mich eine völlig egal also werde
ich dann kam also ja unter den kassen
abgaben seien würste genug fühlen
trennten wir uns über star abgaben in
sachen negativ und bittet alle die sich
einfach denn ich muss sagen am schluss
bin ich nicht so zitiert wurde und dass
das muss ich ganz klar sagen wir hätten
in der schule habe ich mich irgendwie
fühlt als dürftig
[Musik]
also wir sind da in winterthur und ich
tue mir die haare schnuckelig
im haller vom vater gefunden niemand
weiß wie sie danach aber es ist jetzt
mehr draußen oder so mit
solange sie hier wird hätte ich glaube
dass sich otto nicht daran haben
ollila macht mit 17 uhr ist eigentlich
mit der
goldsteiner begriff so dass ihre mäßige
bipa vor so hinter eigentlich nur land
sogar das bitte die länge know how und
jetzt ist er weg
ich bin zwei mal
an
[Musik]
ein happy end
für alles li ning haben kursen
finden so extrovertiert die schule
gehen ist
zurück zwei levels zu können erwiesen
sich
als talent gilt
monogramm ich glaube mit monogramm
geändert dass monogamie nicht
funktioniert also bei mir die szene weiß
david schule gefehlt hier die fände zeit
nicht monogam sie und das wäre nicht
verfolgt das
vertrauen erhalten gibt es eigentlich
gar chris
problemfall also ich finde ich nötigen
wer es ist ich fühle mich verzichten
will eintöpfe nicht gern haben brown
skull finden es normal stoffe gewalt
war was zu finden so versteht dass ich
die einzige die software
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
jetzt glatt harnisch sonne zieht aber
nicht so wie polaris versucht haben
die bezirke und jetzt versucht und es
ist auch für das titel gange und es ist
schwierig sie ja aber ich habe gemerkt
so mitten im rhythmus wenn ich an schaut
so dass ich mir helft die von der woche
oder mehr selbstverwaltung studieren bin
ein viertel wendete am schaffen das
heißt ich bin meistens so 100 prozent
ausgelastet
tagesstunden kann dieser traum ist
einfach wirklich für mich auf
wanderwegen etwas neues etwas anderes
und dann
[Musik]
gibt es geschweige denn zwei oder drei
bereiche
[Musik]
nein
methadon
[Musik]
mit einem job als betreuer in einer
wohngruppe für geistig und körperlich
beeinträchtigte menschen verdient benny
derzeit seinen lebensunterhalt
[Musik]
stofflich
ganz tolle neue schuhe kann nicht gar
nicht so
dann
wird die meisten worden mittag
warum nehmen wir das mal ein herz und
hat mir das okay
herein herein herein herein zu machen
und 10 aha
sagen wir es erstmal heim spiegel
gucken muss porsche spiegel-artikel
sieht dass wir da sind ja
ganz auf qualität
an
ich hätte mir das nie gedankt ich hätte
nie gedacht dass ich jemals in betreuung
schaffen ähnlich hätten ja gut von mir
rabatt und die geduld die haben will
ferner bin ich ganz ungeduldige man
stellen wollen
ich mache ja studium für zum lehrer sie
aber vielleicht bringt es michael wieder
in die praktik der betreuung in angler
und oder in spanien wenn ich jetzt ja
gott spanisch und englisch lernen
wallstadt nach seehofer grad
[Musik]
er hätte eigentlich die treuen wurde
damals kannte sich erfüllt ich weiß nur
dass ich irgendwann mal kommen ich bin
schwul sozialen werte
für das studiere
ich glaube wenn ich jetzt noch mal bitte
zurückgab und die 40-jährige gemeldet
wie so ein glems innerhalb die wenn ich
jetzt lebt ein ventil ab sofort möglich
[Musik]
inzwischen hat matt eine lehre als
fachfrau gesundheit im spital
abgeschlossen
die berufsschule war deutsch und
englisch und die berufsmatura hat sie
auch geschafft
nach einem arbeitseinsatz bei einem
berufsfischer studiert jetzt im ersten
jahr sozialarbeit
das wg leben teilt sie mit anderen
studentinnen
also die wir schon gehört allen
man hat das promi ausgabe 3 und
vollständig der
wgkk galt
ja
hier um zu nehmen sie haben
während der korona zeit kochten sie oft
füreinander und haben häufig zusammen
gelernt
[Applaus]
merritt ist seit sieben jahren mit rasse
zusammen er war schüler im selben
schulhaus wie sie allerdings nicht in
derselben klasse nach einer lehre als
chemielaborant
absolviert er jetzt ein praktikum in
einem jugendtreff
die beiden haben schon mal zusammen
gewohnt leben jetzt aber wieder getrennt
in wohngemeinschaften
[Musik]
so gesehen
wie einfach normal sowie bewusste zieht
für den ort und das eine recht geehrt
wurde darum müsste ich jetzt eine im
moment gerade unbedingt mit dem er wohne
in zukunft dann schon mal oder so
makaber aber im moment ist das hieße ja
so
bieten was funktioniert oder genau also
für mich steht zum
download unter sich nicht
genannt sind sondern dass mir
und risikogebiet will mir nicht
auseinander was sie ja man dass es sinn
macht
[Musik]
ja
wie sie auf die partie vorbereitet das
ist
unser leben
seit irgendwelche typen so bestimmte
länder kommen so verschiedene sprachen
sprechen weil die eingeschworene
gemeinschaft ein tief bei den posten
geist nicht einfach leere worthülsen
sind
und es wird uns um hier sein vorgänger
aussehen wenn jeder weiß doch die
ausnahmen eine behördlich worten auch
nicht immer wieder aufs neue
ich danke euch für diesen einsatz werden
den letzten jahren unsere schule ich
danke für die mitarbeiter und für die
bereitschaft zu werden wie zu denken und
wie zu reden ich bin sehr stolz
feuerwehren gewesen zu sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ganz egal welchen weg sie eingeschlagen
haben sie alle haben sehr viel mehr von
so hediger mitbekommen als der lehrplan
vorgesehen hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also nicht ganz fest einmal sondern ganz
viel wenig
und wieso
weiß nicht ob ich mir klar wurde dass
gesehen sicher die meisten will ich
jetzt fertiggemacht durch die sache mit
dem handy
wird das erst bewusst was das finden
auch
zwei ganz ganz lässig
wir haben da nichts zu sehen
[Musik]